القمه العربيه في دورتها 32 تتزامن مع عدد
من الاحداث التي تشهدها المنطقه العربيه
منها للشبكات في السودان عوده سوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه والاحداث في غزه وغيرها
السفير حسام زكي مساعد الامين العام
للجامعه العربيه قال ان الملف السوداني
سيتصدر ابرز الملفات المنتظره على طاوله
القاده العرب حيث تتواصل الاجتماعات على
مستوى وزراء الخارجيه على هامش القمه بهدف
بحث كيفيه التحرك قدما لتحقيق وقف مستمر
لاطلاق النار لفت السفير الى انه بالاضافه
للسودان هناك ملفات سياسيه مهمه تاتي في
مقدمتها فلسطين كذلك قضيه اعاده عمار
سوريا وعودتها الى الجامعه العربيه بعد 12
عاما من الغياب اضافه الى الاتفاق
السعوديه الايراني الذي تنتظر انعكاساته
على الاستقرار في المنطقه
قال وزير الخارجيه السوري ان دمشق والرياض
لديهما القرار من القيادات في البلدين
بالتقدم بالعلاقات واضاف ان دمشق ستتبادل
مع رياض كل للتسهيلات لاعاده فتح السفارات
في الرياض ودمشق
ونحن سنرحب باي دور ستقوم به الدول
العربيه في هذا المجال هل سيكون الرئيس
السوري متواجدا
كما جرت العاده السوريه لا يمكن ان تغيب
عن اي قمه
كما قلت لا يمكن لسوريه ان تغيب عن اي قمه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات